bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur LCP
ravie de vous retrouver dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir la Neuvième Vague de
covid à deux semaines des fêtes de Noël
le cap des 70 000 quatre jours a été
franchi et le gouvernement préfère miser
sur la pédagogie en recommandant le
masque dans les transports mais est-ce
vraiment suffisant doit-on passer à
l'obligation l'exécutif manque-t-il de
courage ou la contrainte est tout
simplement devenue inacceptable dans le
pays grand débat avec nos invités dans
un instant sur ce plateau notre grand
témoin ce soir et journaliste elle
orchestre tous les matins la grande
interview politique de France Info elle
a décidé d'en montrer les coulisses dans
un film service public en salle depuis
deux semaines l'envers du décor pour
faire la transparence sur le traitement
de l'info à l'heure de la défiance
généralisée salaire brachlia sera avec
nous dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission enfin nos affranchissent ce
soir Stéphanie Despierres nous explique
pourquoi ça caille à l'Assemblée dans
Palais Bourbon Express Britta senberg du
Spiegel permettra le bilan de la
première année difficile de la soltz au
pouvoir en Allemagne et puis électricité
c'est le mot de la semaine qui a choisi
notre sémiologue Mariette Darrigrand
voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
montrer l'exemple mais sans contraindre
c'est donc le choix qui a fait pour
l'heure le sommet de l'État
on n'a pas envie de revenir vers les
obligations généralistes forcément et
donc c'est aussi une manière de
reprendre des habitudes basées sur le
volontariat
[Musique]
voilà c'était donc le président de la
République hier au Conseil national de
la refondation consacrée à la santé des
jeunes pédagogie volontariat esprit de
responsabilité vous l'aurez compris les
mots sont très très bien choisis mais
encourager sans contrainte est vraiment
la bonne méthode bonsoir Catherine Hill
et merci d'être là épidémiologiste une
figure maintenant bien connue des
Français qui traversent maintenant
plusieurs années d'épidémie longtemps à
l'INSERM ainsi que agustave Roussy
bonsoir professeur me garbane ravi de
vous retrouver chef de service
réanimation à l'hôpital Lariboisière à
Paris bonsoir Alexis Isard député
renaissance de l'Essonne bienvenue à
vous votre collègue du rassemblement
national Emmanuel bléri va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
mais d'abord on va faire le point sur le
rebond de l'épidémie puis sur la réponse
des politiques si j'ai bien compris
l'ami blackovski pour ouvrir le bal
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir
on a pas le choix on n'avait pas envie
d'en reparler du covid mais là papa il
coupait je vais devoir vous ressortir la
carte alors voyez quand même la dernière
fois quand on est courbe la courbe mais
c'est plus une cour la dernière fois
qu'on en a parlé c'était la 27 en
juillet on a fait un petit débat la
vague 8 on a fait un peu d'autruche on
voulait pas en entendre parler on en a
jamais parlé d'ailleurs on est au pied
de la vague 9 donc retour du froid même
si la SNCF est en grève quand même mon
mélange de population pour les vacances
de Noël et puis les épidémies qui
viennent s'ajouter la grippe bien sûr la
bronchiolite en plus comment ça
s'inquiéter forcément à quel point que
certains réclament le retour du masque
obligatoire ceux qui s'inquiètent le
plus c'est les plus mis en danger par le
covid c'est-à-dire les 300 000 Français
qui sont immunodéprimés traitement une
maladie
une greffe donc
le vaccin est très inefficace quand on
est immunodéprimé donc il compte
essentiellement sur les gestes barrières
donc ils aimeraient bien que le
gouvernement par exemple décide de
rétablir le masque obligatoire dans les
transports dans les lieux clos enfin un
peu comme on faisait avant quoi sauf que
pour l'instant le gouvernement n'ose pas
aller jusque-là
gouvernement ça serait des dégonflé mais
pas du tout ils n'ont jamais dévié ils
ont toujours dit on demande d'abord la
vie des scientifiques avant de prendre
une décision que les scientifiques ont
changé de nom c'est plus le conseil
scientifique c'est le conseil sanitaire
s'appelle le commerce donc on a posé la
question très simplement faut-il
rétablir le masque obligatoire donc la
question est simple la réponse est un
peu plus compliquée on écoute donc je
répète Brigitte n'ont pas Hélène
Brigitte audre Autrand la présidente du
commerce nous nous disons il faut
renforcer le port du masque de manière
obligatoire ou pas
le caractère obligatoire est un
caractère et une décision qui doit être
prise par les politiques on n'est plus
dans la loi d'urgence sanitaire donc il
ne suffit pas de dire je voudrais que ce
soit obligatoire il y a tout un
processus législatif derrière
on est bien avancé puisque le
gouvernement renvoie la décision au
scientifique qui disent bah non c'est le
gouvernement qui le décidait
effectivement si le gouvernement devrait
ouvrir un débat sur le masque
obligatoire à l'Assemblée je suis pas
sûr que ça soit sa priorité on se
dispute déjà assez à l'assemblée
du côté de la vaccination et là ce
Myriam comme disent les insoumis le
conte n'y est pas regardez où on en est
simplement
20% des plus de 80 ans qui sont vaccinés
donc ils sont vraiment exposés eux
justement des cas graves de colis
pourtant le ministre de la Santé lui ne
ménage pas ses efforts déjà à la mi-nove
il avait il s'était accroché vraiment
des deux mains au signal d'alarme en
disant qu'il y avait 10 morts par jour
fallait réagir donc voilà il n'a pas
hésité à tirer signaler pour celui qui
l'a fait une directive à tous les
personnels soignants pour dire vraiment
le vaccin c'est important rappelant les
catégories d'âge moyen
on reprochait oliveiran à Olivier Véran
d’être un peu arrogant François Browning
n'est pas du tout arrogant vraiment un
peu marre on l'écoute moi je vais
appeler un appel solennel à la
vaccination c'est quand même c'est quand
même totalement absurde on sait que si
on ne le fait pas on va avoir des
problèmes on va avoir des morts on va
avoir une saturation de notre hôpital on
a les moyens de le faire et pourtant les
Français ne se vexinent pas donc on
pourrait évidemment poser la question de
l'obligation de la vaccination comme on
l'a posé pour le masque mais déjà qu'on
n'est pas trop pour le masque
obligatoire au gouvernement est-ce qu'on
est pour le retour du Pass sanitaire
mais justement il y a des bas c'est lui
qui va voilà vous succédez va répondre à
la question merci merci pour ce papier
de présentation Stéphane je vais
commencer avec vous Catherine Hill et
puis avec vous professeur megaban pour
qu'on essaye d'y voir plus clair sur ce
nouveau variant sur cette nouvelle vague
on a regardé les chiffres de du public
France Catherine Hill 71 597 quatre
contaminations ces dernières 24 heures
600 cas c'est le fameux taux d'incidence
pour 100000 habitants donc plus 20% en 7
jours et puis le fameux r en se souvient
du r C'est le taux de reproduction du
virus il est supérieur à 1,2 donc un
malade contamine un peu plus d'une
personne ça c'est une nouvelle vague de
toute façon déjà tous ces beaux
indicateurs reposent sur le nombre de
cas qu'on trouve et le nombre de cas
qu'on trouve un peu à voir mais pas très
précisément à voir avec le nombre de
gens qui se contaminent réellement
puisqu'on test pas tout le monde donc il
y a beaucoup plus de gens positifs que
ce qu'on trouve donc tous vos
indicateurs sont pas les mots les
meilleurs indicateurs c'est le nombre de
gens qui arrivent à l'hôpital parce que
là ils ont pas de choix ils vont pas a
suffisamment mal pour être hospitalisé
et ça ça augmente déjà depuis début
novembre ainsi que le nombre de gens qui
arrivent en réalité 16% hospitalisation
on est passé de
600 par jour qui arrivent à l'hôpital à
1200 par jour qui arrive à l’hôpital il
faut pas non plus prendre les gens qui
sont à l'hôpital ceux qui à l'hôpital
qui sont arrivés il y a 8 jours il y a 3
jours c'est la dynamique du virus qui
nous intéresse donc le nombre de gens
qui arrivent à l'hôpital c'est 1200 plus
de 1200 par jour et ça augmente tous les
jours donc et la vague a commencé quand
on en était à 600 par jour début
novembre donc cette vague elle est là
depuis un mois donc vague il y a pas
donc là dessus c'est l'ampleur de la
vague mon ami ou vaguelette ça augmente
à la même vitesse que dans toutes les
vagues précédentes et on sait pas
jusqu'où ça va augmenter le variant puis
ensuite on ira voilà voir ce qui se
passe à l'hôpital mais
bq-1.1 que sait-on précisément de lui
dangereux plus dangereux moins dangereux
plus transmissible moins transmissibles
on sait pas grand chose il doit être
plus transmissible parce que par
définition invariant qui occupe la place
remplace les autres parce qu'il est plus
contagieux donc ça doit être plus
contagieux et ça a pas l'air plus
catastrophique mais il y a quand même 70
morts par jour très régulièrement depuis
déjà début novembre s'il y avait un
autocar qui tombait dans un ravin tous
les jours en tuant 70 personnes ça
ferait beaucoup plus de même que ça et
là tout le monde s'en fiche mais
complètement
bon on vous retrouve bien là où vous
étiez quand on vous a laissé Catherine
il professeur me garbane à l'hôpital
qu'est-ce que vous observez on avait les
chiffres que donner Catherine Hill à
l'instant on est sur la dernière semaine
à
6771 hospitalisations elles augmentent
plus 7,4% et les admissions en
réanimation vous connaissez bien les
soins critiques plus 14,7% on est à 602
admissions on meurt du covid encore
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital alors pour
répondre à votre question directement
oui on meurt du covid encore aujourd'hui
alors d'abord j'abonde effectivement
dans le sens pris par Madame Hill
effectivement nous sommes bien dans la
9e vague les contaminations augmentent
même si depuis quelques jours la vitesse
d'augmentation s'est ralenti un un petit
peu par contre effectivement comme on ne
dépiste pas tout le monde effectivement
très probablement on est bien au-delà
des cent mille contaminations par jour
lorsque l'on le dépistait avec B1 au
micro on était arrivé jusqu'à 500 000 un
demi-millions de contaminations
le point important le point important
c'est que nous observons toujours une
très bonne décorrélation entre les
contaminations qui sont un niveau très
élevé et les hospitalisations ça n'a
rien à voir avec la première voie la
deuxième vague c'est-à-dire avant la
vaccination
vaccination c'est à dire lorsque l'on a
reçu deux doses plus un appel protège
contre les formes graves de la maladie
mais uniquement c'est ça le point
important les personnes en bonne santé
et jeunes alors ce sont les personnes à
risque
boisière qu'est-ce que vous voyez venir
à La Réunion les personnes âgées de plus
de 60 ans et surtout lorsqu'elles ont
des comorbidités des maladies chroniques
voir une émission elle et bien sont
toujours aussi à risque qu'avant c'est à
dire un risque de faire une
décompensation de leur maladie et de
d'arriver à l'hôpital donc
les poumons ou ça a changé ça ça n'est
plus la pneumonie classique qui
emportait précédemment y compris
quelqu'un de 25 ans sans aucun
antécédence sportif aujourd'hui ce sont
des personnes qui ont des maladies
graves respiratoires rénales cardiaque
chronique et qui a l'occasion d'une
infection virale par la covid dès qu'on
pense leur maladie et donc effectivement
quelqu'un qui a une au sens rénale et
bien tout d'un coup à cause de la covid
il va devoir aller en dialyse quelqu'un
qui a un problème respiratoire chronique
avec l'infection bah oui il va devoir
avoir un respirateur artificiel et ça
malheureusement ça peut entraîner le
décès c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui oui on
peut décéder toujours du covid mais ce
sont les personnes
âgées avec comorbidité qui décèdent
on est protégé contre les formes graves
de la covid si on est en pleine santé et
vacciné si vous voulez malheureusement
le masque quand même une dernière
question et puis ensuite je vais vers
vous mais on a besoin de comprendre un
peu ce qui se passe à l'hôpital comment
vous gérez tout ça parce que on l'a dit
avec Stéphane bronchiolite la grippe la
tension aux urgences ça c'est une
évidence la tension parce qu'il y a un
manque de personnel comment ça va à
l'hôpital déjà est-ce que vous manquez
déjà de lit ou pas c'est-à-dire en fait
effectivement aujourd'hui on a une
conjonction d'infection respiratoires au
même moment la grippe qui va démarrer
qui n'a pas encore vraiment démarré mais
qui va démarrer la covid qui est déjà
en pleine progression et l'infection par
virus respiratoire synchiscal alors je
précise qu'il ne touche pas uniquement
les enfants et qui donne la bronchiolite
qui touche aussi les personnes âgées par
exemple aujourd'hui dans le service chez
moi à Lariboisière sur 18 patients j'en
ai 5 qui sont là pour une infection à
VRS ça montre bien que même les
personnes âgées sont infectées par
donc de fait effectivement on a
certaines pression sur l'hôpital alors
vous n'êtes pas des médecins les plus
alarmistes une certaine pression
2020 ça n'a strictement rien à voir le
problème ici c'est que malheureusement
de façon chronique et prolongée nous
manquons de lui
nous sommes en difficulté parce qu'il
manque du personnel soignant tout ça
parce que le travail à l'hôpital les
conditions de travail à l'hôpital par
exemple au pic de la crise de 2020 nous
avons 5000 lits de réanimation en France
il y en a 500 fermés pour cause de
manque de personnel alors même quand
nous avait promis 2000 supplémentaires
pour atteindre les 7000 qu'on n'a jamais
vu donc en fait aujourd'hui nous avons
4500 donc nous sommes pire qu'en 2020
ce sont les lits d'aval c'est à dire moi
dans le service en animation chez moi
j'ai au moins deux ou trois patients que
j'aimerais bien transférer dans un
service d'aval mais il n'y a pas de lit
Laval il n'y a pas de lit Laval ensuite
on passe à la décision politique parce
que face à cette nouvelle vague il faut
il faut faire des choix vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose alors justement
sur l'hôpital masque ou pas masque c'est
toute la question pour l'instant c'est
la prudence en disant la pédagogie qui
qui l'emporte elles amont d'un GABA et
Philippe lecros ont posé la question à
des Français en pleine course de Noël à
Paris regarder la réponse et votre
intervention juste après
il y a ceux qui prennent leur précaution
pour ne pas laisser le covid jouer les
troubles fêtes on voudrait fêter Noël
avec notre famille et du coup on évite
de l'attraper avant et de d'empêcher de
les voir le 24 j'ai des petits enfants
j'ai des mes enfants aussi la famille
donc ça m'inquiète que en plus pas se
retrouver on voit les personnes âgées on
voit les personnes fragiles sensibles
donc on a envie de passer un bon moment
en famille de se retrouver et pas de
parler de covid mais près des grands
magasins parisiens ce matin le masque
est loin d'avoir fait son retour sur le
visage de tous les Français je l'ai mis
dans le train pour protéger un peu les
personnes âgées si j'en vois quoi bon
c'est tout sinon
j'ai pas le Mas dans le transport je
pense pas très chaud on était un concert
à Bercy personne portait le Portel
masque et on sait même pas posé la
question non franchement non la preuve
voyez je l'ai pas donc s'il faut le
remettre on le remettra mais faut
respirer puis il faudra attendre à vivre
avec alors à l'heure où l'épidémie
reprend faut-il rendre le masque à
nouveau obligatoire par période quand on
sent qu'un petit peu trop de cas de
covid moi je suis d'accord ok quelque
chose qui oblige les gens sinon la
responsabilité suffira pas on l'a vu on
l'a vu les gens ont un peu marre la
conjoncture donc il faut il faut
télécharger
il y a suffisamment d'adultes en France
on peut faire la part des choses je
pense qu'il y a trop de règles et il
faudrait aussi laisser les gens un peu
de liberté et la sagesse de savoir où
quand est-ce qu'il faut le remettre ou
pas
c'est le choix du politique et on a très
bien vu les autorités sanitaires un peu
renvoyé la balle aux politiques la
question de l'obligation elle commence à
monter dans le pays vous vous êtes
député il faudrait voter un nouvel état
d'urgence sanitaire pour rendre
obligatoire ce masque qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez moi je suis David faire
confiance à la responsabilité des
Français c'est à dire de garder ses
bonnes habitudes qu'on avait prises
pendant le covid le choix de la de
l'obligation du port du masque elle a
des conséquences moi je pense à à ses
publics qui ont déjà fait énormément
d'efforts pendant la crise je pense
notamment aux jeunes qui pendant deux
ans n'ont pas les inné sur les efforts
pour protéger les plus fragiles donc je
suis plutôt d'avis de faire des efforts
mais faire des efforts il va falloir les
faire plus amplement quand on regarde le
taux de vaccination des personnes
sensibles il est trop faible aujourd'hui
il faut que les personnes sensibles
elles aient se faire vacciner moi je le
dis aux personnes qui regardent cette
émission si vous en côtoyez autour de
vous emmenez-les se faire vacciner
pousser les affaires vacciner si vous
envoyez souvent vous-même faites-vous
vacciner on a un problème là-dessus
c'est que les personnes fragiles sont
trop peu vaccinées qu'on arrive dans la
phase de l'hiver ou forcément les virus
hivernaux
à partir d'un certain âge le vaccin si
on fait pas peser l'obligation sur le
masque je crois que déjà il faut il faut
sensibiliser un maximum de personnes à y
aller pendant la crise du covid les
personnes fragiles de l'encouragement
les personnes fragiles pendant le covid
sont partis se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui il faut qu'elle le sache et
qu'elle il y a une campagne d'ailleurs
qui a été lancée la campagne de
vaccination a été lancée début octobre
on a déjà près de 2 millions de doses
qui ont été dose de rappels qui ont été
qui ont été faites il faut continuer à
le faire massivement Emmanuel bléri je
vous fais réagir dans un instant mais je
voudrais vous faire entendre Mathias
wargon vous connaissez sûrement Mathias
wargon médecin urgentiste à l'hôpital de
La Fontaine en Seine-Saint-Denis lui
clairement il tape du point sur la table
écoutez
on a décidé de pure merder les gens avec
le masque ça veut dire quoi ça
moi je pense que c'est un manque de
courage politique oui les gens ne
veulent plus du masque on le voit bien
on voit comment on se fait insulter
parfois par certains sénateurs on est
sur Public Sénat moi j'ai été insulté
par des anciens sénateurs et des
sénateurs
on se souvient arrêté d'emmerder les
Français c'était Pompidou qui disait ça
mais quand il s'agit d'un enjeu de santé
publique est-ce que c'est pas la
responsabilité des politiques de passer
à la contrainte franchement je pense que
les Français sont responsables justement
on a subi des années enfin des années
quelques mois en tout cas de restriction
absolue on a quantifié le coup financier
mais on n'a pas quantifié le coût moral
de tout ce qui s'est passé ces derniers
dernières années
ont été infantilisés il a fallu faire
des attestations pour la faire faire
pipi aux chiens sous comment dire la
menace d'une amende ça les Français
n'ont pas oublié sur ma circonscription
j'ai croisé beaucoup de mes concitoyens
ces dernières derniers jours vis-à-vis
cette question et la question n'est pas
pour ou contre le port du masque
mais globalement globalement même dans
l'hémicycle on peut lire certains de nos
collègues c'est un étang bien avant les
effets d'annonce et de communication du
gouvernement portée parfois le masque je
suppose qu'ils avaient peut-être des
suspicions de covid où j'étais en fin de
covid je ne sais pas
ça fait déjà quelques semaines quelques
mois que les Français même dans le métro
et dans nos avions dans nos TGV certains
portent le masque donc ils sont assez
grands ils ont compris
donc mais peut-être que les autres
l'obligation de le faire pour l'instant
voilà et puis il y a autre chose
c'est impossible on a trop payé de
contraintes le pays ne supporterait pas
c'est ça on en a fait le calcul il y a
eu des aujourd'hui il y a une contrainte
morale et laissez-moi juste finir
là-dessus parce que je je le disais je
rencontrer des des Français qui me
parlaient du climat anxiogène qui était
réinstaurée là ces derniers temps
puisque le ministre de la Santé a
déclaré si je n'abuse je ne tremblerai
pas du bras pour imposer obliger le port
le port du masque B quand il s'agit de
nos libertés en réalité il faut trembler
du brame le pays des libertés et des dès
lors qu'il s'agit de mettre au centre et
au cœur des débats la liberté des
Français il faut trembler il faut
réfléchir je préférais que le ministre
de l'Intérieur ne tremble pas pour
évacuer nos écunset aujourd'hui vous
êtes plutôt en phase avec la stratégie
d'encouragement de responsabilisation du
gouvernement c'est mais globalement en
fait on écoute aussi il y a deux choses
nous sommes des hommes et des femmes
politiques nous avons scientifiques qui
ont fait le constat tout à l'heure très
bien on en prend acte on voit aussi ces
chiffres on est au pied d'une deuxième
enfin du deuxième par nom du deuxième
vague et il y en aura d'autres
certainement il y en aura d'autres
certainement les Français ont été faut
le dire médiatiquement harcelés pendant
des mois c'est-à-dire que vous le petit
compteur en bas à droite qu'indiquer le
nombre de morts à la seconde près
quasiment on arrête d'en parler non je
ne dis pas ça je ne dis pas ça je dis
que les Français ont compris il y avait
d'autres comment dirais-je d'autres
moyens de des interpeller simplement
avec de l'information de la vraie de la
bonne information sans apporter ce
climat anxiogène on en a pas besoin de
la formation à partir des scientifiques
qui sont venus chaque soir et je
repenseur demain c'est la crise et on
est dedans mais demain au mois de
janvier c'est la crise énergétique et
demain c'est la crise sociale avec la
retraite donc laissons tranquilles les
Français les Français ont besoin de de
d'être en paix il faut laisser
tranquille les Français
il faut dire des choses qui soient
correctes et ce cet insistance sur cette
querelle du port du masque est vraiment
un truc très marginal dans l'affaire si
on pouvait contrôler la circulation du
virus en portant sérieusement des
masques ça se saurait les vrais outils
qu'on a en magasin c'est la vaccination
et c'était une utilisation rationnelle
des tests qu'on a jamais fait la
vaccination vous étiez vraiment
l'avocate
on a dépensé en argent monumental en
testant n'importe qui n'importe comment
c'est pas une stratégie on avait les
moyens de faire autrement du
gouvernement n'en a pas voulu n'a pas
cherché même à comprendre l'intérêt des
tests groupés la vaccination la
vaccination alors la vaccination c'est
très intéressant parce qu'on est en
train de perdre un temps fou médiatique
à parler des masques qui embêtent tout
le monde et on laisse les gens en faire
on va finir par laisser les gens faire
ce qu'ils veulent parce que personne ne
veut
juste préciser pour ceux qui nous
regardent parce qu'on est à la chaîne
commentaires qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait
une nouvelle loi un nouvel état
d'urgence sanitaire à moins d'un décret
qui serait validé par le Conseil d'État
s'il n'y a pas d'atteinte excessive aux
libertés publiques voilà je ferme la
parenthèse avec 70 morts par jour
personne n'attention de refaire une loi
donc cette histoire
le vaccin parlons du vaccin le vaccin
d'abord on a très mal vacciné les gens
de 80 ans et plus parce qu'il y a 13 %
de cette population qui n'a pas du tout
été vaccinée alors que le nombre de gens
qui n'a pas du tout été vaccinés aux
âges en dessous de 75 ans c'est plutôt 5
ou 6% pourquoi il y a deux fois plus de
gens qui n'ont pas été vaccinés chez les
gens les plus fragiles parce qu'on n'est
pas allé on n'a pas organisé la
vaccination la sécurité sociale c'est
très bien qui n'a pas du tout été
vacciné et ils font envoyer les
vacciner chez eux parce qu'ils sont pas
mobiles ils ont pas de famille qui peut
organiser un rendez-vous et organiser
une ambulance pour les transporter etc
donc bien un énorme trou le deuxième
trou c'est qu'on répète depuis quelques
semaines que la vaccination couverture
vaccinale n'est pas bonne mais personne
n'a expliqué aux gens qui devaient aller
se faire vacciner alors que c'est très
simple si votre dernière vaccination
Dadia plus de 6 mois et votre dernier
covid date il y a plus de 6 mois vous
devez aller vous faire revaxiner parce
que l'efficacité de vaccin diminue au
bout de trois mois il a déjà perdu pas
mal et au bout de 6 mois il a perdu
suffisamment tous les gens donc
voilà allez-y tu as terminé puis on va
faire répondre la majorité allez-y
c'était simple pourtant et c'est ça
qu'il faut dire à part sauf que si vous
avez plus de 80 ans c'est plutôt si
votre dernier vaccin ou votre dernier
covid date depuis 3 mois mais pour tout
le monde
si leur dernier dose date il y a plus de
six mois ou leur dernier covida depuis 6
mois il faut qu'ils aillent se faire
vacciner maintenant c'est clair mais ça
n'a pas été dit clairement Alexandre
rizard vous êtes point pardon alexis a
vous êtes pointé du doigt vous faites
partie de la majorité on entend le mot
de pédagogie la pédagogie c'est informer
les gens une grande campagne est
nécessaire on l'attend toujours la
grande campagne elle a commencé début
octobre le problème c'est peut-être que
à force d'entendre parler du copide
c'est du covid pardon c'est peut-être
devenu un petit peu inaudible et on a
plus envie de l'entendre mais la
campagne elle a lieu quand vous nous
dites qu'il fallait vacciner les
personnes chez elles les départements se
sont mis au mis en place des des des des
vaccinations mobiles pour aller chez les
gens maintenant on peut pas forcer les
gens on peut pas les vacciner de force
et ça deux fois plus d'antivax au dessus
de 80 ans
vous l'expliquer ce chiffre ce sont des
personnes âgées qui refusent de se faire
vacciner ou c'est un problème de
vaccination qui n'arrive pas jusqu'à
chez elle la vaccination elle a été mise
en place pour pouvoir justement on a eu
des vaccinodrome
sur place et on en a eu des mobiles
aussi donc la vaccination elle a été
mise en place pour pouvoir aller chez
les gens et garder la communication bien
sûr et sur mais sur la communication
sont à jour de leur de leur rappeler et
ça c'est terrible et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pousser ces personnes là sensible à
aller se faire vacciner la réalité c'est
que on a vu
on a vu beaucoup de personnes sur les
plateaux télé allez faire peur à cette
population là qui est déjà fragile et
qui s'est dit que finalement le vaccin
allait leur faire plus de mal que de
bien et c'est faux il faut qu'elle se
dise que le vaccin ne leur fera pas plus
de mal que le bien le vaccin valait
protéger
au contraire c'est pour ça que sur le
fond de ce que vous dites je suis
totalement d'accord sur la communication
moins de 6 mois vous retournez vous
faire vacciner connectez-vous sur
doctolib ou sur une autre plateforme
vous verrez si vous savez très bien
merci vous avez 85 ans vous allez pas
vous connecter quoi comment on
accompagne les personnes âgées est-ce
que là c'est pas tous les six mois c'est
plutôt tous les trois quatre mois avec
heureusement pour nous la campagne de
vaccination auprès de la cible de cette
vaccination de personnes les plus âgées
n'a pas marché parce qu'on a utilisé des
moyens pour toucher les plus jeunes qui
en pratique ont
quasiment aucun à recevoir une nouvelle
dose
pourquoi on voit au Royaume-Uni 85% des
plus de 80 ans ont reçu leurs doses de
rappel avec le vaccin bivalent
ils ont reçu leur date de vaccination
directement et quand il ne pouvait pas
se faire vacciner on leur a envoyé un
transport pour les vacciner ou quelqu'un
pour les vacciner donc 85 % des gens se
sont fait vacciner donc peut-être les
quelques réfractaires ne l'ont pas ne
l'ont pas fait mais on est allé vers eux
on leur a donné un rendez-vous mais on
n'a pas diffusé une information à la
télévision dans sous forme publicitaire
que les personnes âgées ne regardent pas
ou ne comprend pas et on n'a pas envoyé
des tweets on sait par avance qui ne
consulte pas ça il faut être beaucoup
plus proactif en allant directement vers
les personnes les plus fragiles Emmanuel
Blairy le rassemblement national était
contre le passe vaccinal en tout cas
obligatoire il y a eu beaucoup de
polémiques sur vos positions notamment
qui pouvaient parfois donner
l'impression que vous n'étiez pas
franchement Provins pas tous mais dans
vos rangs qu'est-ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui
sur le retard de la vaccination des
personnes âgées est-ce qu'il faut tout
faire pour que pour qu'elle le soit
votre propos j'étais parti des députés
qui ont voté contre le Pass vaccinal en
début de l'année dernière encore une
fois parce que nous sommes au pays des
libertés je pense que même sans ces
mesures coercitives les Français avaient
tout intérêt pour ceux qui étaient
effectivement
âgés ou ceux qui avaient des problèmes
de colombidité avait je pense
l'intelligence de d'aller se faire se
faire vacciner
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les autres
80%. qu'est-ce que vous vous proposez au
rassemblement national encore une fois
est-ce que est-ce que la vaccination
empêche la transmission est-ce que la
vaccination empêche de comment dirais-je
d'absorber ce virus de prendre ce virus
je ne suis pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr
voilà je suis pas sûr donc ça c'est ça
aussi ça c'est du factuel
scientifique ça protège un moment
encore une fois pas de la science on
écoute nos scientifiques bien sûr pour
prendre certainement des mesures demain
politiques mais écoutez à parler
scientifiques on écoute aussi l'ensemble
des Français madame voilà qui ce qui
m'ont dit mais oui parce que parce que
vous comme moi on a tous autour de nous
des gens qui ont tout on a tous des gens
autour de nous qui ont été vaccinés et
qui vous disent bébé 2 mois après
j'étais pourtant jour de vaccination
j'ai attrapé le covid je l'ai refilé à
mon grand-père et à toute la famille
voilà donc ça c'est une évidence donc
professeur il faut pas dénigrer le
vaccin parce que effectivement il y a
tout une musique qui passe dans les
médias en disant le vaccin finalement
n'empêche pas la transmission ça n'était
pas ce qu'on lui demandait vraiment ce
qu'on lui demandait c'est de nous
protéger contre le risque de mourir
d'aller à l'hôpital et ça c'est
parfaitement efficace d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on se permet tous ces débats
sur le Mas soit-il le mêle pas le mettre
etc parce que la couverture vaccinale de
base est correct en France parce que
effectivement une personne qui n'a aucun
problème médical et protéger contre le
risque de mourir avant nous tous ici
on pouvait mourir moi-même j'ai soigné
des gens je me disais dans quelques
jours je pourrais à sa place en train de
mourir
en charge puisqu'on a un manque de place
c'est comme 17500 lits qui ont été
supprimés sous le quinquennat précédent
d'Emmanuel Macron donc si on a confiné
le pays si on était aussi coercitif
c'est parce que
soigner c'est bien sûr votre le cœur de
votre métier mais tous ceux aussi qui
ont pas pu être soigner qui sont restés
chez eux parce que
et de surcharge des hôpitaux bien sûr et
on en a largement parlé Emmanuel bréléry
à ceux qui nous regardent vous leur
dites quoi qui ne serait pas encore
vacciné dans les publics fragiles allez
vous faire vacciner est-ce que vous
pouvez leur dire je veux que vous je ne
suis pas mis de la santé ni préféré ni
comment dire le prénom de la République
pour se dire ce genre de choses je
laisse ça aux autorités compétentes non
moi je dis simplement je dirais je
dirais conscription faites-vous vacciner
mamie peut-être qu'il serait préférable
d'aller mais elle a sa liberté aussi
madame à la salle liberté qui suis-je le
point imposer ce genre de choses à qui
que ce soit je pourrais imposer des
choses dans l'hémicycle de par mon vote
ou ne pas imposer vous jouerez pour je
voudrais compte voilà la position d'un
homme politique Madame Catherine
deux choses avec le l'arrivée du variant
au micro-ondes on l'a perdu
la possibilité de dire le vaccin protège
de l'infection parce qu'on sait que
maintenant ce variant contamine des gens
qui sont vaccinés ou qui ont déjà eu le
covid donc la vaccination maintenant
n'empêche pas la circulation du virus
cependant elle empêche elle réduit
beaucoup le risque de maladies graves et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que l'hôpital
s'en sort pas si mal avec un virus qui
circule énormément il y a eu une
expérience très intéressante en vrai
grandeur un papier qui vient de paraître
aux États-Unis
dans l'Ohio et en Floride pour voter il
faut s'inscrire comme républicain ou
comme démocrate parce que comme ça on
peut voter aux primaires si le système
sur la liste électorale il y a marqué
vous êtes républicain vous êtes
démocrate il doit y avoir aussi marqué
vous êtes indépendant mais
des chercheurs ont regardé la mortalité
comparée la mortalité des démocrates et
des républicains depuis 2018 en âge du
stand comparant à AG =
base géographique assez petit égal donc
dans le même coin résultat et résultat
en 2018 ils ont ils ont comparé chaque
mois de 2018 au mois de 2019 chaque mois
de 2020 au mois de 2019 chaque mois de
2021 au mois de 2019 après 2009 la
mortalité était supérieure la mortalité
était exactement pareil entre les
républicains et les démocrates en 2018
comparé à 2019 exactement pareil ensuite
en 2020 c'était pareil jusqu'à ce que le
covid on a vu une petite surmortalité
des républicains et au moment où le
vaccin est arrivé alors les républicains
sont morts deux fois et demi plus que
les démocrates le vaccin protège de la
mortalité c'est assez j'ai envie de dire
est-ce qu'on a pas là la preuve que
scientifiquement et infutable que le
vaccin protège et qu'il faut
l'encourager je ne sais pas si on a la
preuve scientifique avec ce genre et
encore une fois on prend l'exemple
américain puisque la bande ils ont
peut-être la chance ou la malchance de
faire des listes entre ceux qui sont
républicains démocrates noirs ou Blanc
Nez
en France
faire de liste vérifier si ceux qui
n'ont pas été vaccinés de statistiques
je parle pas ceux qui ont d'hôpitaux
mais est-ce que est-ce que quand on est
pas vacciné et qu'on transmet le virus
est-ce que le virus est à moins de bruit
ou inférieur dans sa capacité de nuire
je ne sais pas on n'a pas cette réponse
le débat touche à sa fin je vais vous
donner le mot de la fin Alexis Izard
cette expérience elle a un fait
extrêmement importante c'est de mesurer
la parole que les politiques ont et
l'importance de la parole des politiques
sur les décisions que prennent ensuite
les administrer et c'est pour ça qu'il
est extrêmement important qu'on soit
clair nous notre décision les décisions
qu'on doit prendre en tant que politique
et pas en tant que médecin c'est de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on protège au
mieux la population du risque de décès
du covid et des autres virus qui
arrivent on parle de la broncholite mais
aussi de la grippe qui qui n'arrête pas
d'augmenter donc il faut protéger les la
population et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
qu'on les avances les amène le plus à
aller vers le vaccin et apporter le
masque dès qu'ils sont malades dès
qu'ils sont avoir le moindre symptôme
merci beaucoup pour ce débat à la fois
scientifique les politiques de
l'importance de la responsabilité des
décideurs merci à vous d'être venu sur
le plateau LCP on va accueillir à
présent notre grand témoin elle est
journaliste aux manettes du 830
politique avec Mark Fauvel la grande
interview de la matinale de France Info
à la décider dans montrer les coulisses
dans un film service public c'est le
titre documentaire en salle depuis 2
semaines salut abraclya nous rejoint
juste après les meilleurs extraits
compilés par Marco pommier regardez
si on vous invite Salia braquia c'est
pour se plonger dans les coulisses de
votre matinale à France Info une
rédaction en ébullition durant la
dernière présidentielle des bas entre
journalistes échange avec les politiques
anecdotes sur le vif vous avez tout
filmé tu sais bien qu'avec la marche
d'erreur
vous êtes journaliste l'interview
coulisses montré ce qu'il y a derrière
les discours c'était votre spécialité au
Petit Journal sur canal+, puis à
quotidien sur TMC passée par BFM TV vous
êtes depuis 2020 une voie de France Info
tous les matins vous cuisinez les
politiques avec Marc Fauvel et
aujourd'hui vous consignez avec Mouloud
Achour ce documentaire service public
opération transparente sur l'art de
préparer une interview politique être
journaliste sense improvise pas on ouvre
les portes on vous montre comment on
travaille et on va essayer de mettre fin
à tous les a priori tous les fantasmes
que vous avez que vous avez en tête
cassez les fantasmes sur les relations
entre journalistes et politiques votre
obsession délivrée une information
fiable ne pas s'éloigner des faits à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux et de la
alternatives une ligne de conduite qui
ne convainc pas vraiment le garde des
sceaux
en fait parce que ça après ça fait
allégeance donc comme vous êtes soucieux
de votre indépendance alors
on le dit
opinion non et parfois vos questions à
gaz Marine Le Pen peut tenter hors
caméra micro coupé elle la présidente du
rassemblement national était furieuse
après une de vos questions sur son
salaire
sur ce sujet vous croyez vraiment que
c'est un test les gens ça on a fait
toutes les questions qu'il me semblent
importantes c'est 30 secondes
alors Salia brachiya une question ce
soir y a-t-il une chose que vous
n'auriez pas montré dans votre
documentaire à vous la parole
bonsoir Célia brachlia merci d'être là
donc le pari de la transparence pour
tendre le cou à tous les fantasmes à
tous les a priori sur ce métier de
journaliste d'abord c'était courageux de
faire ça et puis c'est salutaire et pour
répondre à la question est-ce que vous
avez vraiment tout montré non on n'a pas
tout montrer par définition parce qu'on
a on a tourné pendant 10 mois ça fait ça
on accumulé près de 200 heures de rush
on en a fait un film d'une heure 16 donc
oui par définition on n'a pas tout
montré on n'a pas mis c'est marqué ça
mais on n'a pas mis ces mauvaises
blagues ça c'était une évidence parce
que déjà qu'elle n'était pas très bonne
donc on allait pas l'afficher davantage
ce qu'on a pas montré comment on choisit
alors quand on a autant de rush quand on
est en salle de montage avec Mouloud
qui est mon courrier coréalisateur
j'étais pas seule parce qu'il fallait
quand même il fallait c'était normal et
obligatoire un œil extérieur je pouvais
pas être le sujet et la réalisatrice
uniquement donc Mouloud a amené son œil
extérieur en faisant justement le choix
de sélectionner des séquences que
moi-même j'aurais sélectionner celle
qu'on vient de voir que Marine Le Pen je
l'aurais pas mise parce que ça me met en
porte-à-faux et puis j'aime pas me voilà
c'est une séquence qui me met pas en
valeur une autre avec Jordan Bardella
pareil ou je sors de mon on va en parler
là vous allez trop vite d'abord facile à
convaincre le marque Fauvel la caméra au
petit matin au saut du lit et toute
l'équipe de la matinale ou pas ça fait
jamais plaisir d'être filmé tous les
matins
quand on sort du lit effectivement mais
en fait non ils ont tous vraiment joué
le jeu et puis ils ont tous oublié la
caméra au bout d'un moment on tourne à
tourner sur sur 10 mois pendant une
semaine ils étaient tous comme ça une
bougie au bout d'un moment relâche parce
que Charlotte Gauthier donc qui qui
tournait bah elle était elle faisait
partie de l'équipe
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est autant un film sur les coulisses
entre les journalistes et les politiques
à l'hôtel mais aussi beaucoup en
rentable mais moi ce qui m'a intéressé
le plus c'est que c'est aussi un film
sur l'interview politique comment on l'a
fait l'interview comment on choisit
c'est quoi
une bonne interview politique Célia
Braga alors nous on a voulu montrer
comment on construisait une interview
politique parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
fantasmes autour de ça moi j'ai eu des
amis même des que des gens de ma famille
qui m'ont dit toi tu reçois tes
questions de l'Elysée et puis voilà tu
les répètes le matin ça quand on entend
ça ça nous rend dingue concrètement donc
je me suis dit il faut montrer comment
ça se passe là dans le cadre du 8 30
c'est 23 25 minutes d'interview en
direct la veille c'est 4 heures de
préparation c'est-à-dire qu'avec Marc on
a une obligation c'est d'être calé sur
tous les sujets sur lesquels on va on va
questionner les invités donc ça peut
être un moment on devient expert covid
un autre expert croissance ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est qu'on voit
comment vous choisissez les thèmes
toutes les discussions en amont qui fait
que par exemple avec Zemmour on va
l'attaquer sur le pouvoir d'achat et pas
sur l'immigration la question de savoir
à quel moment on l'invite avant ou après
qu'il ne soit candidat en fait rien
n'est laissé au hasard et c'est ça qu'on
découvre avec le film on se dit tous les
matins avec avec Marc il est où
l'intérêt de recevoir quelqu'un peu
importe la personnalité politique peu
importe son bord politique si on
l'interroge sur sur des sujets dont on
connaît déjà les réponses en fait et
donc c'était le cas pour Erik Zemmour il
venait de faire deux mois de promo avec
son bouquin où il parlait immigration
sécurité bah nous quand on le reçoit
déjà on le reçoit quand on considère
qu'il est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et en plus on va
l'interroger sur la priorité des
Français le pouvoir d'achat ce moment-là
une bonne interview c'est tout sauf un
débat avec votre invité et vous n'êtes
pas là pour donner votre avis c'est ce
que vous rappelle gentiment mais assez
fermement quand même Jean-Philippe bail
le directeur de France Info à vous et à
Marc Revel c'était important qu'elle
soit là cette séquence là aussi mais oui
parce que oui vous remontre les
bretelles oui il le fait régulièrement
heureusement qu'il est là parce que on
fatigue et parfois on se laisse emporter
par nos émotions
l'objectif chez France Info c'est d'être
le plus neutre possible possible
de jamais donner notre avis et c'est
pour nous c'est la base de notre métier
de journaliste on est on n'est pas des
éditorialistes on est des interviews le
but de l'opération Tous les matins c'est
de d'avoir des réponses de ce qu'on
invite de l'éclairage de faire avancer
le débat et pas d'avoir un débat
nous-même on n'est pas des
contradicteurs on peut avoir des
arguments pour justement essayer de
taquiner l'invité et savoir jusqu'où il
va mais on n'est pas là on n'est pas des
personnalités politiques qui défendent
des positions alors justement restez le
plus neutre possible autant que c'est
faire ce peu il y a les coulisses avec
les politiques ça on le voit ça se passe
en général plutôt de façon amicale
certains en profitent quand même pour
tendre un peu l'atmosphère on le voit
bien avec Eric Dupond-Moretti il y en a
qui qui testent leur punchline ça c'est
Bernard Cazeneuve mais une fois hors
micro bah vous n'hésitez pas à dire ça à
un certain Jordan Marvel
non mais c'est que je me sens beaucoup
plus proche de ce qui se passe en
Ukraine que ce qui se passe en Syrie ou
en Libye que ce soit les Syriens les
Libyens c'est la guerre aussi
géographiquement ils sont plus proches
de nous
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que je voulais je vous ai
posé la question c'était pour savoir
quel était vraiment le fond de votre
pensée et concrètement c'est on
accueille pas s'il s'agit de musulmans
ou d'autres religions
des migrants etc c'est toujours très
défavorable et là l'Ukrainien c'est pour
y compris chez un électeur parce que
parce que les gens sont pas parce que
les gens disent ça que vous-même à la
télé responsable politique à la tête
d'un grand parti vous pouvez le dire
aussi je veux dire vous me pensez quoi
personnellement vous pensez ça allez
passionnante cette séquence parce que
certes il faut rester neutre autant que
possible mais là c'est salé à brachlia
qui en tant que citoyenne est choqué par
des propos et qui n'hésitent pas à le
dire à son invité backstage là on est
dans la petite salle la petite loge
maquillage on a l'impression que la
caméra est oubliée là vous êtes choqué
mais vous vous lui dites et vous
l'assumez ça ouais je l'assume alors
c'était difficile de la mettre dans le
film je l'avoue je sors de mon rôle
totalement je devrais pas faire ça
je suis déjà je le fais pas à l'antenne
et c'est une obligation
et Or En teine il m'arrive de faire des
choses pareilles mais quand ça touche
effectivement au plus profond de soi là
on j'entends un une personnalité
politique de premier plan dire en direct
ben en fait on va choisir les gens en
fonction de leur religion ce qui
catastrophique les réfugiés qui
demandent l'asile oui pour les
Ukrainiens qui sont chrétiens non pour
les Syriens qui sont musulmans c'est
totalement inconstitutionnel de faire ça
je le précise parce que s'ils avaient
gagné les élections quelque chose me dit
que ça n'aurait pas été possible à moins
d'une énorme réforme de la loi suprême
n'empêche que vous lui dites que que ça
vous choque et pourquoi c'est si
compliqué il y a une autre séquence Eric
Zemmour qui dit au fond l'objectivité ça
n'existe pas il faut être honnête là
vous êtes honnête et ça n'est pas
l'interview je précise bien est après
c'est après et je pense que les gens ne
comprendraient pas que je le dise à
l'antenne en fait c'est ça qui est
difficile les gens se moquent de mon
avis et ils ont bien raison de toute
façon ils appelaient il est pas plus
important qu'un autre en revanche moi je
n'aurais pas pu laisser jardin de
Bardella partir comme ça sans lui dire
parce que ça me tenait trop à cœur on
l'a pas dit à l'antenne mais en revanche
on l'a contré sur l'effet rien que les
faits c'est-à-dire si vous si vous
proposez ça ben en fait vous pourriez
pas l'appliquer ce qu'on voit aussi
c'est qu'ils sont susceptibles surtout
quand ils sont candidats à la présidence
ils jouent évidemment leur avenir et
parfois même leur vie politique
Mélenchon qui préfèrent vous dire qu'il
fait plus de vues en posant avec un
chien qu'en faisant une interview avec
des journalistes ça pourrait arriver
c'est une campagne présidentielle son
journaliste un jour non moi j'y crois
absolument pas ils ont tenté en 2017 en
2022 ils ont tenté de nous squeezer de
voilà de de faire sans les médias
traditionnels la vérité c'est que les
Français ont confiance en nous alors de
c'est violent ils ont c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait ce film aussi c'est que la
défiance elle est grandissante mais il y
a quand même un un truc qui rassure
quand on regarde un jT TF1 JT de France
2 On est des journalistes il faut
rappeler qu'on travaille qu'on travaille
beaucoup et contrarié avec rigueur les
candidats qui ont essayé de faire sans
les médias traditionnels et ben ils ont
perdu ils ont pas touché une grande
partie de la population notamment les
plus âgées
j'allais dire c'est c'est pas une bonne
manière c'est pas une bonne stratégie de
faire de faire campagne ceux qui font
les deux réseaux sociaux et médias
traditionnels ils assurent plus Emmanuel
Macron vient vous voir parce qu'il y a
évidemment tous les candidats qui
viennent sur France Info pendant cette
campagne il vous glissent ainsi qu'à
toute l'équipe que quand il fait des
bains de foot il est assez terrifié
terrifié d'entendre toutes les fake news
terrifiées d'une forme de poste vérité
dans laquelle on aurait presque déjà
basculé vous-même comme journaliste ça
vous terrifie bien sûr comme vous je
suis connecté à tous les réseaux sociaux
que ce soit Twitter Instagram Tik Tok
snapchat je vois les trucs les théories
qui veillent qui sont véhiculées ce que
ce que repose les jeunes c'est
terrifiant c'est vrai ça nous oblige
nous à être davantage vigilant on
vérifie nos propres informations c'est
normal c'est notre job on va vérifier
aussi les les informations qui buzz sur
les réseaux sociaux parce qu'il y a
certains politiques qui les reprennent
aussi sans qu'elles soient vérifiées
justement et ça c'est problématique
quand il y a quand il y a une personne
responsable des politiques qui se
servent des réseaux sociaux pour faire
campagne sur des mauvaises informations
là ça devient problématique et nous
notre job de journaliste c'est de dire
bon bah voilà on va à la fois vérifier
les informations qu'on sort et ceux qui
sont sur les réseaux sociaux ça inquiète
le président de la République bah il a
raison parce que bah lui il a été aussi
victime de ça pendant la campagne en un
mot les retours du public je sais que
vous organisez beaucoup de projections
avec les Français il y en a une ce soir
je crois à Paris c'est ça qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit alors pour évidemment
tous ceux qui ne sont pas journalistes
qu'est-ce qui marque dans ce film on me
dit d'abord merci d'avoir ouvert les
portes il y avait beaucoup de fantasmes
dès qu'on ouvre les portes d'un endroit
où les gens n'ont pas accès ils sont
contents et ils voient un peu plus
comment ça se passe et puis surtout ce
qui est étonnant c'est qu'il se dit là
je savais pas qu'un tel était comme ça
tel ou telle politique était comme ça en
vrai et puis la troisième remarque qui
nous revient et qui nous choque aussi
parce que ça veut dire que vraiment il y
a du il y a du boulot à faire c'est on
savait pas que vous travaillez autant
voilà c'est un travail c'est un vrai
travail
parfois même laborieux un travail
d'artisan merci beaucoup Célia merci
abraklia donc service public surtout
quand on se lève très tôt comme vous
service public s'étend sale un peu
partout en France faut y aller parce que
voilà pour qu'un film reste en salle il
faut qu'il trouve de son public avec
Mouloud Achour bien sûr c'est important
salut à vous restez avec moi c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchis pour
leur parti pris ce soir il fait froid à
l'Assemblée pourquoi ça caille dans les
bureaux Stéphanie DESPER va nous le dire
dans sa chronique pas les Bourbon
Express Brita Sandberg du Spiegle
reviendra sur la première année assez
difficile de la Scholtz au pouvoir et
puis électricité c'est le mot de la
semaine qu'elle choisit notre sémiologue
Mariette Darrigrand comme chaque
vendredi nos affranchis au féminin
pluriel bonsoir mesdames et ravi de vous
retrouver Stéphanie on sait que les
Français ont baissé leur consommation
d'électricité EDF l'a montré pour le
mois de novembre à l'Assemblée aussi
apparemment et ça il fait froid ça
caille qu'est-ce qui se passe alors on
beaucoup parlé des débats enflammés à
l'assemblée de la température qui
montait et des députés sur le point d'en
venir aux mains et bien on a trouvé
quelque chose qui fait désormais
consensus dans l'hémicycle c'est la
doudoune de Sacha Ollier le président
renaissance de la commission des lois en
passant par Kevin Pfeiffer du
rassemblement national Xavier Breton des
républicains ou encore en version
féminine Perrine goulet du MoDem c'est
tout sans doudoune et même la gauche s'y
met comme vous le voyez l'écologiste
Benjamin Lucas car désormais bien il
fait frisquet sur les bancs alors que
les députés à débattent en ce moment de
la loi sur les énergies renouvelables et
bien au Palais Bourbon aussi on a baissé
le chauffage l'insoumise Raquel Garrido
qui est né elle au Chili a choisi la
version andine de la doudoune je vois
que vous avez un poncho est-ce qu'il
fait froid dans l'hémicycle alors c'est
pas un poncho c'est une Johanna en
alpaka et parce que la différence est le
poncho c'est juste un trou au milieu et
la Juana c'est un truc comme ça en fait
comme ça et donc si ça vient du Chili et
effectivement c'est très très chaud
c'est très chaud et effectivement il
fait un petit peu frisquet en ce moment
et donc j'ai pas mis de col roulé parce
que j'en ai pas ça me va pas bien mais
je mets Maroine et puis parce que le col
roulé c'est un peu trop marqué
gouvernement c'est le nouveau look
macroniste d'avoir un col roulé
le fameux col roulé remis sur le devant
de la scène politique par Isabelle
donc le ministre de l'Économie déclare
dans une interview qu'il a troquée la
cramé contre le col roulé pour faire des
économies preuve à la pluie publie la
photo sur Twitter alors cela lui a value
évidemment quelques sarcasmes mais il a
fait des émules à l'Assemblée en journée
en ce moment il fait 19 degrés dans
l'hémicycle alors c'est col roulé ce
n'est ni l'usine ni la mine ni en
extérieur les députés ne se plaignent
pas mais comme on voit des Français ils
découvert en version il découvre en fait
qu'avec cette température quand on ne
bouge pas et bien on a un peu froid nous
avons adopté des mesures de sobriété
donc effectivement il fait 19 degrés
donc ça dépend de chaque du ressenti de
chaque parlementaire c'est important de
montrer l'exemple est-ce qu'on a froid
aussi en grelotes aussi dans l'hémicycle
ou enfin que dans les muscles ou
ailleurs et ben un peu ailleurs parce
que ce magnifique palais Bourbon a été
construit en 1722 et c'est encore une
passoire thermique difficile à chauffer
mal isoler conséquence des thermomètres
ont été ont été installés dans tous les
bureaux certains députés nous disent
qu'il fait 18 voir 16 et demi dans le
leur collaborateur et fonctionnaire
disent aussi du bout des lèvres que
aussi il se caille notamment dans les
couloirs et dans les grandes salles les
plus anciennes il y a même un numéro
interne dédié pour demander
d'éventuelles à réparation de chauffage
ici à l'Assemblée alors cette année le
chauffage a été allumé plus tard l'eau
chaude est limitée dans les sanitaires
l'éclairage est réduit la nuit elle sera
coupée pendant les vacances
parlementaires et c'est vraiment
le jeu écologique il y a aussi un enjeu
financier l'assemblée a dû débloquer des
fonds supplémentaires pour payer la
facture
l'Assemblée doit montrer l'exemple c'est
important on peut pas demander aux
Français de faire des efforts et pas
aller faire soi-même en plus on les
regarde à la télé si on voit qu'ils sont
tranquillement et la sobriété
vestimentaire on en parle beaucoup vous
étiez au quotidien des années Marc Baugé
connait sa Parker la bile la politique
la doudoune le col roulé on sait que ça
marche ça auprès des Français ah que
c'est ce que ça les incite
les politiques pour s'habiller et
heureusement
c'est pas forcément très très efficace
bon alors sans doudoune mais avec un
magnifique quoi veste et charmant
collier Brita vous allez nous parler du
Beagle vous allez nous parler de la
schols le mystère olafals après après sa
première année comme chancelier
social-démocrate allemand voilà parce
que cette semaine donc le 8 décembre ça
fait un an qu'il était chancelier il
reste pour les allemands comme pour ses
amis Ali ailleurs dans le monde assez
souvent
incompréhensible donc un vrai énigme et
pourquoi tout d'abord je souhaite s'il a
le tempérament des Allemands du Nord ça
veut dire
il parle très peu il n'aime pas parler
et contrairement Emmanuel Macron c'est
pas il aime pas la mise en scène et les
longs discours gardez son calme en plus
rester calme et pour lui une vertu et en
ce temps de crise aussi un devoir pour
un chancelier afin de ne pas inquiéter
les Allemands c'est ce qu'il a dit
récemment
ce qui donne comme résultat un
chancelier qui est plutôt pâle et
énigmatique et à côté duquel Angela
Merkel a soudainement l'air d'une femme
qui était expressive il y avait presque
un temps Paramé latin quand elle rendait
visite par exemple à l'équipe du foot on
est vestiaire et toute l'équipe était à
moitié torse nu ou alors quand elle
embrassait tendrement votre président
Emmanuel Macron oui elle avait un petit
faible on a senti le fringues
a écrit cette semaine je cite c'est déjà
remarquable si je Schwarz ne lit pas la
déclaration du gouvernement sur le ton
d'un notaire qu'il y a un testament ça
vous donne une petite impression ah oui
effectivement à cela on peut ajouter une
certaine forme d'arrogance aussi on a
l'impression que il aime bien faire la
leçon la chose voilà il a en plus enfin
quand il parle des avantages qu'il peut
paraître arrogant des Spiegel le
magazine pour lequel je travaille donc
essayez de comprendre l'origine de cette
attitude en faisant des recherches sur
les livres qui lient puisque les
chancelier lient beaucoup mais lis pas
de romans mais que des ouvrages
pratiques sur la politique la sociologie
par exemple et en permanence qui lit des
heures résume dashbigle cette lecture
fait de lui un donneur de leçon
quelqu'un qui sait toujours mieux que
les autres et quelqu'un qui est parfois
un peu loin du monde qui l'entoure alors
en revanche il a pris grande décision
depuis notamment l'avion en Ukraine il
faut quand même rester juste il a
déclaré un changement d'époque dit ce
qui est déjà le mot de l'année en 2022
en Allemagne et un budget spécial de 100
milliards d'euros pour l'armée allemande
il a également annoncé que l'État
allemand investira 200 milliards pour
combattre les effets de la crise
énergétique mais là aussi il ne
s'explique pas il n'informe pas non plus
ses partenaires en Europe et en France
avant une telle déclaration Marc
l'échangeait parfois quotidiennement des
textos avec Emmanuel Macron Schots a
l'air de préférer le grand silence la
question maintenant c'est est-ce que
c'est juste une maladresse ou plus
est-ce que notre allié notre ami ou pas
est-ce qu'il est toujours un ami de la
France et un Européen convaincu à
l'écrit quand ces discours l’énigme se
prononce d'une façon très claire il a
défendu en Europe souveraine et forte en
son discours à Prague pendant cet été
même s'il n'a pas mentionné la France
beaucoup dans ses discours et ces
jours-ci la publier un texte dans le
magasin
donc elle parle de l'Allemagne comme le
garant d'une sécurité européenne donc
moi je crois qu'il y a aucun doute que
une Europe plus forte et qu'il a vu
aussi en lien étroit avec la France mais
il faudrait peut-être qu'il sorte qu'il
sorte un peu plus de sa bulle qu'il
arrête d'être si calme qui commence à
parler bref qu'il change de temps
apparemment et à 64 ans c'est jamais
facile de se dériver
mais à Berlin on entend que la
Chancellerie ils disent d'avoir
sous-estimé les sensibilités du côté des
Français ces dernières semaines et que
le chancelier et ses conseillé en
premier de faire mieux désormais
rendez-nous Merkel
elle a vu passer pas mal de nos
présidents français en plus toujours une
relation chaleureuse bon à différents
degrés selon le président en tout cas ça
a l'air d'être Macron oui c'est vraiment
tous les opposes c'est vraiment très
très opposé mais on pensait que il était
au début assez semblable à Merkel et en
fait maintenant
elle était pas non plus très chaleureuse
mais on a toujours dit qu'elle était
très
il y a encore plus c'est possible
mais là où c'est important dans le fond
c'est que effectivement quand il fait
des plans à 200 milliards sans prévenir
c'est c'est ses collègues européens
c'est problématiques quand même parce
que ça nous impacte aussi directement
nos entreprises directement et notre
défense aussi on termine avec le mot de
la semaine Mariette comme chaque
vendredi cette fois-ci vous avez choisi
en ces temps de menaces de coupure de
courant entre le gaz russe qui nous a
été coupé par Poutine coupure chez nous
aussi peut-être de parler d'amour
l'électricité ah oui vraiment on
retrouve la fée électricité elle est
vraiment la star de nos médias cette
semaine vous connaissez ce ce gros ce
magnifique tableau qui est encore
d'ailleurs au Musée d'Art moderne à
Paris de Raoul Dufy on voyait la fée
électricité alors là on est dans les
années 30 c'est l'exposition universelle
de 37 ça veut dire une époque où le
progrès célébré et célébré à travers des
allégories
l'industrie la technique la prospérité
et donc on a cette fée électrique il
faut dire que c'était un peu magique
c'était complètement de l'électricité
l'arrivée voilà au début c'est quoi
c'est le 20e siècle c'est que du 20e
elle s'installe dans les foyers
européens et là évidemment c'est tout à
fait magique alors aujourd'hui c'est
tout à fait banal d'allumer
l'électricité mais quand on est menacé
d'en être coupé alors la magie se
retourne ce serait vraiment épouvantable
cauchemar économiser l'énergie bah tout
le monde le fait aujourd'hui au risque
d'avoir un peu froid évidemment ça c'est
possible mais en être coupé en être
privé c'est vraiment absolument
impossible alors par analogie parce
qu'il y a pas de causalité mais ce qu'on
voit en Ukraine les coupures en Ukraine
les gens qui sont dans le noir en
Ukraine ça nous ça nous fait un tableau
encore plus dramatique la coupure
d'électricité comme arme de guerre voilà
alors l'électricité ça vient doucement
alors ça vient il faut pourquoi est-ce
que le coupure s'est intéressé c'est
parce que ça nous rappelle effectivement
l'origine du mot électrique je viens de
l'ambre en fait c'est pour ça qu'on la
coupe finalement on peut retrouver notre
mémoire culturelle retrouve quelque
chose elektron en grec ancien c'est
l'ombre blonde qui brille et donc là on
est c'est très très ancien c'est 600 ans
avant Jésus-Christ on a Thalès de Millet
le fameux Thalès qui frotte une peau de
chasse sur un morceau d'ambre et là il
découvre l'électricité statique donc ça
vient de là et à l'héroïne mythologique
Électre elle était appelée comme ça
parce que précisément elle était
irradiante de beauté d'érotisme à
l'électricité l'air donc ça renvoie
toujours un imaginaire assez gai
finalement et festif oui oui absolument
ben regardez à Paris quand la Tour
Eiffel est illuminée c'est quand même il
y a quelques avis de lumière reprend et
malgré justement les économies d'énergie
actuelle ça n'a pas été arrêté ni les
décorations de Noël donc il y a quelque
chose en effet qui est très positif mais
je voudrais boucler là dessus c'est que
j'ai l'impression que la nouvelle fait
électrique fait électricité aujourd'hui
c'est la voiture électrique elle est
paraît absolument de toutes les vertus
même si certains experts faut mettre des
bémols mais c'est quand même si cette
fée électricité elle nous redonnait foi
dans le progrès et elle nous met dans
une nouvelle elle nous fait prendre
conscience et d'ailleurs une petite
ampoule d'un tête dans les BD tout d'un
coup on se dit nous aussi on vit une
révolution industrielle comme au 19e
les coupures à venir et donc sur le plan
du langage là-dessus je voudrais finir
mais rien pour proposer quelque chose
allez-y il me semble que le fameux mot
de transition énergétique dont
personnellement je suis un peu fatigué
parce que transition ça fait 20 ans
on regarde ce qui se passe en ce moment
on se dit que le vrai mot c'est
électrification de notre société ben
voilà une proposition pour le débat
public arrêtons avec la transition
passons à l'électrification merci
beaucoup Mariette je signale qu'une
épopée du féminin et dans les bonnes
librairies c'est votre dernier essai
Amazon sorcière DS
voilà tout tous ces exemples du féminin
positifs dont on peut voilà puiser dans
l'histoire merci beaucoup merci Salut à
bracelia et bonne route avec service
public et puis le 8 30 politique avec
Marc Fauvel tous les matins 8h30 bien
sûr sur France Info Brice a son Berg et
bien sûr Stéphane idée pierre excellent
weekend à vous deux et à vous tous sur
LCP bien sûr à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]